let's play John oh I have a Dada Dada
John one two three four five six seven
eight
Oh John has been adopted don't remember
doing the paperwork what to play against
John John a Sicilian I feel like I
played every opening imaginable let's
just play let's play something I'm
choosing opening this game playing
Knights III don't remember playing the
scenes tune but it's possible I played
this against him because I've been in
this predicament before oh how long will
I stream at least for another at least
for another hour I don't like making
promises but I'm gonna try and get in at
least like ten more games if not more
thanks chess pay fair for asking g6
Jonathan g6
I'll play E for the trying trick trick
him into like a modern my cc5 here play
d4 kind of some kind of weird Sicilian I
think I actually covered this line in a
lecture for st. Louis Jeff's club was it
called crush the Sicilian with 293
except this was 193 yeah so the idea is
to play Bishop b5 discouraging this and
then click file
and then tell fun trying to kick kick
the night around mmm yeah so if you sub
then you still have to use a leech s
command sure so just say exclamation
point we chess space and then your leech
s username people have been doing it you
should figure out how to do it hopefully
we're not f3 here ah
so Jon play the delay Brooklyn ah maybe
they call it the Brooklyn because when
you when you arrive in Brooklyn you
probably don't want to be there so they
can just leave it's like the night
arrives to f6 and just says never mind
but actually no offense to Brooklyn it's
a nice place no black has a bishop hair
it's okay let's just castle
fuzzy Gardens NYC born nice yeah no I've
been to end my see like many times over
the years we'll hopefully go back when
we've being settled down like Bishop f4
is nice move actually the food like the
food not only in Brooklyn but all over
New York City is probably some of the
best food on the planet
okay the focus on chess my threatening
this might be this would be a crazy move
to play east six just unleashing like
double discovery it probably doesn't
make any sense I probably just loses a
piece too cuz but I can take the pawn
and attack my Knights but this looks fun
so many fun options
I'm also considered in queen like
Queenie for or queen b-52 in Queenie for
and Queenie for Bishop e7 how to do play
Queen C for yeah the problem with these
two moons were there should be seven I
was looking for four tricky moves but at
least on c4 it's hard for luck to attack
the Queen right away I keep the bishop
defended so it's still this idea which
would then also have a battery against
f7 hey it's ash pool John you have
another John thanks for subbing at tier
1
yeah Queen III would have been very
similar whoo so this prevents e6 but
very weakening to g6 I think I I think I
managed to trick John with the opening
it's something outside of the comfort
zone let's play this move and still
probably requires some calculation does
my age 6 and this move
and c5 is very hard to defend
Oh have I been to martial chess club I
have I was actually in New York in
January but didn't have a chance to
visit oh wow
lose this move I forgot about that move
I'm just losing material but thankfully
actually I'm not losing material I have
this move
let's play this move yeah marshal very
historic place if you're a chess player
in New York you should definitely make
an effort to visit and I assume when
when they opened back up there'll be and
there there's always like weekly almost
daily tournaments a new subs we have
Salvi sale and lawrence
harry and the massive raid wow it's naca
it's GM hikaru breeding with close to
1,500 people thanks so much
shadow Tanaka yeah if you don't know who
naka is Alexa who said karo Nakamura
better know this one oh that's probably
incorrect kind of just take always want
the Sun yeah thanks so much not gonna
appreciate it yeah things just paid to
Java of GM Macario should give him the
follow some doing a lot of streaming
these days oh yeah worth 45 million
dollars right
I got read by a dead person
pretty sure knock is alive hopefully um
hi dear the check the chat is going more
more quickly than I'm used to I still
have to focus what to do me this move
this tricky move this is very tricky I
feel like there's 95% chance blacks
about to get forked on the next move or
at least within the next like two or
three moves there's so many Forks as I
was threatening this where's my fork
like all I want to do is fork stuff rook
to you on routine one looks nice like
there are so many traps I give this and
this oh yeah
well thank you high jinks high jinks
recommending good hygiene it's an
appropriate username okay what's
happening well do these nights are so
majestic but how do I actually do damage
can put the Queen here just pinning this
this night like the king is very close
to getting Maiden
why didn't he take the Queen was a queen
hanging don't know if the Queen was
hanging unless something was missed
saying who is Hikaru Nakamura is like
asking who is Jesus Christ yeah
kind of close close enough earlier
earlier there is there is pimp Jesus in
the chat it was an interesting username
okay no this is so nice I'm trying to
calculate like Knight c8 open then
Bishop takes seeds like what's the
threats I just want to start stacking
stuff in 1987 it's a fun move Knight c4
is a fun move let's take on g7
yeah life is torture the Queen before
winning Queen asked again to question
kind of thanks for your feedback
you're welcome this move was a nice kind
of party in the center if King g7 again
night c4 wins the Queen otherwise I
assume I'm I'm threatening some sort of
like force mates it's like 95 King here
here here and then 95s covered
while kindy it's trying to hide the hi
my nights it's not the best hiding place
but how do i I'm just looking for a
beautiful meet life goals let's play
this bikini Yeats I'm not seeing force
mate hey Eric harm
thanks for the bits
like Queenie for okay the Queen and
Queen has swung so the Queen side where
it belongs and now now it's a fork okay
yeah it took more than a few moves to
fork but the fork has has arrived so
yeah if you're just joining maybe I
didn't explain what I'm doing I'm
playing subscribers similar to what I
assumed NACA was doing earlier if you
want to subscribe most people know how
you can subscribe for free with Amazon
Prime and then you can challenge me have
a challenge command if you're a
subscriber there's a way to make your
name purple which hopefully the mods can
can tell you what to do in the chat
oh no yeah it was unfortunate
unfortunate circumstance thanks for the
game time
one tip this is actually a completely
fine line to play for luck but rather
than Bishop g7 I recommend a six there's
actually a game yeah I think I showed
this in my lecture for st. Louis Chess
Club
there's a scheme where black one in like
14 moves
this is two grandmasters this was
actually played at the Parapan American
collegiate championships and the black
player was a teammate of mine on La
Hoya's why play queen 8 for v6 was
incredible how quickly lack one this is
a very nice move defending the rook
which attacks the bishop also
threatening g2 and then Bishop f1 was a
sad move but probably necessary and then
the black built up Bishop takes a to
advice black was just completing winning
here and white just resigned as a funny
game so yeah play a six I would have
played e5 and then it requires further
study but it's it's a reputable line if
you know it well oh the bishop and Queen
and your two knights and rooks root and
the other Bishop were very annoying yeah
that's the goal of chess is to just make
your pieces annoying